[Música]
bienvenidos a medio ambiente en france
24 la pérdida de masa forestal o vegetal
es una lacra que afecta a todos los
rincones del planeta pero esta semana
hablaremos de este problema abordado
desde tres ángulos y desde tres zonas
del continente americano comenzamos en
el norte seguramente hayan visto las
imágenes de los incendios en california
en lo que va de año y en el momento de
grabación de este programa las llamas ya
habían devastado unas 600.000 hectáreas
de terreno lo que equivale a unos
850 mil campos de fútbol aún hay 10
incendios activos en el estado entre
ellos dixie convertido en el segundo más
grande de la historia de california que
lleva ardiendo desde mediados de julio y
aún está fuera de control las causas de
estos incendios pues son varias algunos
empezaron por rayos otros por chispas
del tendido eléctrico pero la mayoría
han sido provocados por nosotros los
humanos y todos tienen algo en común la
sequía persistente que sufre el oeste de
eeuu así que por un lado tenemos la
deforestación por causas humanas
indirecta como el calentamiento global
que nosotros aceleramos con las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
por ejemplo y que contribuyen a que haya
incendios más graves y más
frecuentemente viajamos ahora un poco
más hacia el sur y hacemos una parada en
centroamérica concretamente en panamá
aquí abordamos el tema desde el segundo
ángulo como las acciones directas del
humano sobre la cobertura forestal
tienen efectos en los animales de la
región el jaguar único de las américas
ha perdido más del 70% de su
distribución original en centroamérica y
méxico desde inicios del siglo 20 la
destrucción de su hábitat natural para
darle paso a cultivos poblaciones o
actividades ganaderas amenaza al animal
y a muchas otras especies que viven en
el corredor biológico mesoamericano un
programa de conservación creado en 1997
que tiene zonas protegidas que van desde
el sur de méxico hasta panamá y que
conectan zonas de migración de animales
oscar sulbarán corresponsal de france 24
en panamá nos amplia
un transitar fugaz en un espacio cada
vez más reducido así es la realidad de
los jaguares en panamá una especie
propia del continente americano para
este biólogo una eventual extinción de
estos felinos también afectaría a largo
plazo la zona selvática del corredor
biológico mesoamericano si el jaguar y
los otros depredadores no existe jaguar
puma que son los más grandes que tienen
la capacidad de poder matar sea y no
venados por los de montanier que es
conejos pintados si ellos no son muchos
no controlan la población de esas
especies entonces cuando los árboles
comienzan a fructificar y si ellos son
muchos barren con todas las semillas y
qué ocurre después el árbol en algún
momento se cae por alguna razón y si no
hay semillas no crece nada no hay una
regeneración del bosque ese bosque esa
selva que hoy se ha reducido es sólo uno
de los problemas a los que se enfrentará
también este pequeño puma
una de las amenazas más graves por el
jaguar es la matanza que se hace en
estos animales como en represalia porque
estos animales en ocasiones atacan a los
animales domésticos de los ganaderos
euclides es un ganadero con más de 40
años en el oficio durante ese tiempo
sólo ha perdido siete de sus reses está
convencido de que no es una costumbre de
los jaguares atacar al ganado salvo
cuando
los campesinos van de cacería a buscar
proteína animal y coinciden con que el
jaguar va detrás de una manada de
puercos monte o de sahin o de venado
interrumpe en la acción del jaguar el
jaguar se viene se sale entonces cuando
queda desorientado se sale entonces a
buscar básicamente terneros para evitar
que los jaguares se crucen con el ganado
y con los seres humanos es crucial la
conservación de este corredor biológico
una zona que además a partir de 2022
servirá para realizar un censo de la
especie única de las américas y
finalmente nuestra corresponsal en
caracas visitó a una de las muchas
familias en venezuela que debido a la
escasez de gasolina ya los persistentes
cortes eléctricos que ha sufrido el país
en los últimos años han tenido que
pasarse al uso de la leña para poder
cocinar los conservacionistas ven con
preocupación que la crisis
socioeconómica que vive venezuela se
convierta en una crisis ambiental
nelson pérez vive en esta humilde casa
en una barriada de maracay ahora memoria
de la capital caracas es hora de
almorzar y nelson ya se prepara para
comenzar la faena
armar un fuego en el patio de su casa
para cocinar con limón
comenzamos a cocinar con leña desde hace
cinco años la leña es la única opción
para él también para miles de
venezolanos que enfrentan escasez de gas
doméstico y cortes eléctricos
recurrentes pueda dañar la sacamos el no
ser cada domingo el hijo de nelson y un
vecino recorren por horas varias vías de
la ciudad con una carreta vacía y un
machete en busca de troncos que usarán
en la semana
enrique garcía ambientalista y director
de la ong de sembramos todos denuncias
se cometen delitos ambientales es un
ecocidio de de gran magnitud porque si
bien se puede estar haciendo de a poco
en varias partes de la ciudad se está
haciendo consecutivamente nelson y su
familia viven en pobreza extrema forman
parte de los setenta y 9.3 por ciento de
venezolanos en esta condición según una
encuesta privada de un ciudades del país
el hijo de nelson y su vecino josé ya
van de vuelta a casa tienen la
carretilla llena de troncos con lo
conseguimos en el suelo arrancar
un machete por si acaso no pasa nada
nadie reconoce tala el hijo de nelson y
josé simón volverán el domingo a buscar
mientras la ong sigue sembrando árboles
en un intento por disminuir el daño
ambiental
como ven las razones pueden ser diversas
pero el resultado al final es el mismo
la destrucción de la biodiversidad
mundial es todo por esta semana hasta la
próxima